- Most people, when
they think of a jockey,
think of a male jockey.
People who don't think
women can be jockeys
are uneducated.
Obviously, we are proving ourselves.
I've become the first female jockey
to win the Melbourne Cup.
It took 150 years for
a woman to finally win.
My name is Michelle
Payne, and I am a jockey
and horse trainer.
Horse racing has been part of
our family before I was born.
My dad was a jockey and a horse trainer,
and my older brothers
and sisters all followed
in his footsteps.
I was very lucky growing up
with a family, where,
it wasn't ever suggested
that female jockeys couldn't
be as good as the male jockeys.
And I think that really helped me.
The Melbourne Cup is the
race that stops the nation.
It's such a huge event in Australia.
As a jockey, it's what we all aim towards
from as young as four or five years old
it was basically my
dream to become a jockey
and to win the Melbourne Cup.
So, I felt very privileged to have been
the first female jockey to win.
(camera shutter snaps)
It was a moment of disbelief.
It was a moment of years of training
and dreaming of winning our
greatest race in Australia.
It was an amazing feeling.
I think the racing industry is great,
because men and women compete equally
and there's no separation
between one or the other.
In the generation coming through,
we've got a lot more female apprentices,
and I think that's fantastic.
What I'd say to young children
who would like to be a jockey:
don't let people say you can't,
because obviously, it is possible.
That, for me, has been
the most important part
of winning the Melbourne Cup.
Showing and proving to
young girls coming through
and current jockeys that it is possible.